the i-team has learned that police are
looking for two teenagers in connection
with a murder and fire discovered on
friday
police say a man was killed and then a
fire was intentionally set to cover it
up
it happened at a home right near durango
and west cliff the i-team's vanessa
murphy has uncovered some new
information
she is live outside metro police
headquarters now joining us with more
vanessa
brian we've learned police are searching
for a 16-year-old girl and her
year old boyfriend both are considered
suspects
police tell me the 16 year old girl
stole
the victim's car sources say both teens
have been missing since
at least friday now that's when
investigators say the body of a man in
his 40s was found in this home
in the west part of the valley after a
fire was intentionally set
to possibly cover up the crime the
property owner tells the i-team that
daniel halsef
was living in the home with his teenage
daughter
health says loved ones tell the eye team
they're aware of the investigation
and they provided this photo of him the
clark county coroner's office has not
confirmed the victim's identity though
now halseth is the ex-husband of
elizabeth halseth
a former nevada state senator she has
since remarried and changed her last
name when reached by phone sunday she
said she has no comment
court documents show daniel and
elizabeth have three children
including a now 16 year old girl now
the family of the 18 year old boyfriend
has hired an attorney for him
that attorney tells me the family just
wants both teens
to return safely and that the family is
fully cooperating
with police also police have not yet
released
the teen's names reporting live vanessa
murphy 8 news now